this is what is about it's a combat art
but it's
it's the art of love means that when you
do silla
and you apply it no violence must be in
your heart
no violence must be in your feeling you
have to have totally salam
like when you say someone
[Music]
salah then you met it
then imran will strike me for example
here's a basic box
another strike
it's a more advanced strike like this
even though they look a bit dangerous
sometimes but there's no bad intention
there's pure mohammed and it's
controlled
and then there's enough that's called
boa
or means the fruit falls from the tree
so when the fruit falls it doesn't
expect you when you catch me or
so one submits the food submits and the
person
takes so one does something that one
submits
the next stage is when people improve
they've got moving harmony together
this way is learning this
[Music]
so when you learn this knowledge you're
not meant to use your mind
you're meant to use your heart so you
don't think
because you don't know what's going to
happen because everything other makes it
happen
so if you use your mind you're going to
get stuck thinking you need to do this
you need to do that
when you don't use your mind whatever
the person does to you
you can just like a leaf that falls from
the tree
you just let go it all happens
it's naturally about allah that's not
human
we need to relax we need to accept
everything
that's my acceptance because you feel
like you need to run away
because you feel like the block
acceptance is you attack me
you're not really doing anything to me
bjj
stop